hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma now we're about
to go into the basement and I'm fairly
certain that there's gonna be a whole
lot of monsters down here but I don't
want to make many assumptions so here we
go oh this looks red and fun oh I can't
wait to see hold it high well that
surprised me I am a little confused I
was just being sarcastic I didn't expect
weird things to start happening
immediately what is wrong with you sir
what happened that's I have no idea okay
is that what it was telling me about how
there's people that are kind of human
but not exactly unconvincing life and
environmental control seems to be
functional purifiers waste management is
failing
Recycling's not doing too good these
people don't care about the environment
okay then I guess I guess that's all it
was just a fun surprise to be down here
there's some bizarre life support system
for whatever the hell that manor may not
be
okay that was a fun door let's see
what's in this door oh good oh yeah
that's not good
oh I had such a sneaking Oh
mmm hey hey whoa gosh is that what's
happening to Amy back in the transport
area
I honestly can't tell if there's
actually something down here with me
uberta boop okay well this is fun
boy okay all right then well I'm an
expert of these types of experiments I'm
brave
you're an [ __ ] well how about over
there I know right that was weird huh
why is a baby squealing in my ear
oh no that's huh that's not good what do
I do
oh let's not do that I'm feeling
something all the way oh trying to make
noises to get it to go somewhere but it
doesn't seem to want to follow anything
a little bit yeah that was loud and
noisy oh oh no no whoa whoa hey whoa
Nelly whoa Nelly whoa
okay mainframe seems good I did it
please stand by
manual confirmation needed
oh crap
hello sir not this way hi oh oh oh oh no
no no no no I mean it's curious as I am
to see how you look to be proved huh I
don't want to get a good look at you I
mean no offense but I think your
horrendously ugly and my my my frizzy my
first fish my my face can't take your
face oh wait oh oh God
I gotta do this quick no no no [ __ ] that
[ __ ] let's let the [ __ ] huh did I do
it did I do it did I do it did I do it
I'm not good in crisis situations I
crack under pressure
I cave I came very quickly under
pressure okay
I think I did something good so now I
can go back upstairs and experience all
the joys of whatever the hell was
waiting me after I did all that oh I see
thank you I'm just glad he didn't break
on me well that was the thing sure I'm
happy that that went that way good job
son
this better have worked I'm not going
down there again
yeah no joke there are some fun noises
coming from that door oh I wonder the
wonderful wondrous things that could
await me underneath there what is going
on okay someone's having a tasty snack
I'm gonna guess that's a cafeteria
someone's enjoying a nice juicy sloppy
joe this is it sloppy joe Thursday gimme
that was on the computer what did you
use it for it's a template that has an
intelligence powers thinking with all
the people scanned for the okay someone
must have had access to the dumb back if
you find a scan of someone who knew the
security cipher maybe we can extract it
somehow extract from what what exactly
am I looking for look for the large
racks of data chips in the storage next
to my lab should be plenty to choose
from
okay I know what that is but at least I
got an objective now and that tells me
what I need to do so now I should be
able to go upstairs and access all the
computers and stuff I kind of did want
to see or hear what you know what she
was gonna talk about before she got
interrupted there but oh well beggars
can't be choosers hey I have to live my
life with the decisions that I have made
all right oh I see so I'm gonna be
putting personalities into this computer
okay that's it okay what is this imaging
read ah that's the person they were
talking about what's an equal American
or thing Linder huh flow tank scan room
beach I don't know what any of these
means for say us do not use wait do not
use this one what would happen okay
I want to make a copy of that last one
because it seems dangerous really the
first time check the storage whoa
thank you okay alrighty then what about
the one that sounds fire and all zappy
he's don't looking like they're in good
shape just being honest here uh damaged
fast huh all right they all look like
they're damaged broken
huh so where am I gonna find a good one
I mean I guess it's gonna be obvious
when I see it damn it's damn dude that
looks good I like this good okay an
intact memory chip before lucky we might
be able to extract the cipher from it
okay time to resurrect someone from the
dead I guess here we go
where do I put it in where do I shove my
thing into where do I slam my hot day to
chip in do just give me an open port and
I'm gonna go at it is this it will you
accept my hot thrusting data huh anyone
want my cipher oh how about this over
here nope not that how about in here oh
yeah this is what I'm talking never mind
okay I am laws just give me a location
with which to thrust my chip I just want
to go at it hot and heavy
I'm ready guns blazing what do I do
where do I put it I'm so confused sorry
it's my first time I'm inexperienced at
this I just can't figure out where to
put my chip come on give me give me a
clue guide me in talk to me talk dirty
to me talk science to me well okay I'm
maybe was over in the other room maybe
wasn't even in this room maybe I was
confused in that completely wrong oh of
course I was yes I was in the total
wrong area oh I keep getting lost like
that trying to shove it in places it
doesn't belong
oh well that's my process see if there's
anyone who could know a security cipher
okay so I'm looking for someone of a
security type Marx Arang that sounds
familiar
killed himself the continuity Brandon it
doesn't really say
what they do okay
I guess I could just go from top to
bottom I kind of do want to talk to
everybody no we need someone for data
security okay they had a security group
that actually does make it a little
better so it's not even gonna let me uh
how would I know though we look alike
what about marks Turing I heard his name
before so maybe the Machine outside was
actually talking about more either look
for security people in constant or oh
you could just told me that in the first
place okay so there's no Kronstadt or
stone meyer
working for stone Meyer
very promising I'll just load them up
and get the simulated going okay we'll
see you in avens there we are what are
we doing exactly we're gonna have a talk
with mr. Wong use the computer to
activate the simulation that wasn't so
bad
from I really got me worked up bastard
what what happened what did everyone go
take it easy mr. Wan Chun what happened
they I can't see anything there's
nothing here don't worry mr. Wan it'll
all get better oh that's a lie
you're lying mr. Wan I need you to stay
home
no no why are you why are you doing this
to me I trusted you John I trusted you
oh we just bring that guy to life
I mean he's a perfect scan but for the
arm he's the real deal we turned him off
took it all the way again I really
thought that was gonna work maybe we can
try again try again on the same person
or should I load up someone else I don't
even know if I can at this point okay
that wasn't so bad it's from I really
got me worked up bastard what wow what
did everyone go mr. Wan Chuck whatever
they I can't see anything
there's nothing here it's okay it's all
part of the scam that's a lie you're
lying
don't get upset mr. Wong no no why are
you why are you doing this
I trusted you John I trusted you - shut
up won't work we need something else
okay so Oh the info that's right in the
other room there was also environments
that I could send things to that's right
I could oh that's what that was all
about it makes more sense now okay so I
need a different test environment see
flow tank water filled seal tank sensory
limiter scan room with pilot seat better
continuation not necessarily for the ark
agreeable exterior test verse il do not
use okay so I can actually can't use
that one but maybe the beach no flow
tank
okay scan room with better environment
what no I need a new blue ah there it is
okay there's simulation assets in that
one okay so if I take I put this back in
there I didn't see this thing of
simulation assets so this is a
simulation as it do I need to load it up
I might need to load it up first there
we go got it okay all right I've got a
chip all right okay chip environment
local 44% three so I got a there's a
beach in a ski log Lodge which could be
used but I could also get the other ones
for so corrupted data so can't use that
one scan room B the chip then get the
float tank in there oh I can't even get
the float tank all right I guess I'm
just doing the hand room okay all right
I want to try the beach in the ski lodge
though I think that would be fun Boop
okay I didn't pull a chip cuz I'm a big
dummy that's what I get for leaving my
chip in unfamiliar slots gotta always
remember to protect myself boys use
protection when you're copying over your
internal assets yep
markiplier the only guy that can make
computer simulation stuff slightly
sexual and very uncomfortable how about
the beach no I'm so bad from I really
got me worked on bastard what Mr Wong I
need your help dr. China's thank you
what happened what is this place
just be calm take a deep breath and
enjoy the scenery for a moment dr. Chuck
I hear your voice but there's no one
here there's no one here it's too empty
there's something really wrong this
place it's not real this isn't real
I have to get out of here well then all
right he had fun in that one hood off
can we just keep them alive until we've
got the cipher the longer he's exposed
to the computer model the more he'll get
hung up on it so what's wrong with
letting him settle in a little it would
drive him insane so let's keep the
session short and the suffering to a
minimum okay ski lodge this should be
good I'm so bad it's from I really work
dumb bastard what
versus where am i take a deep breath mr.
Juan everything is fine is it huh
is it fine it's fine time to explain I
need you to give me the new security
cipher why are you doing this is this
some trick I'm not giving you anything
I'm trying to save a lot of people no
you're lying
this is all aligned [ __ ] joke
get me out of here Charl pot you cheated
huh boy he stood up he's gonna need to
build a scene so it's more what he'd
expect uh-huh as soon as he starts to
doubt we've lost him I know I know these
things more data I need these I know
these things if I I already knew the
answer I just wanted to see how it was
for so that from are really gonna be
worked out bastard
Oh congratulations mr. Juan the scam was
successful John where's Alice she's fine
we don't have much time mr. Juan I need
the new security cipher what why why
would you then this is a trick no it's
okay I promise you couldn't be trusted
none of this is real but you won't break
me well you here is you all right me
okay so there needs to be something else
like an addition to this do this come on
siren don't give up Wow okay so I need
to add something else to the chip as
well or in addition to everything else
so there's got to be something else here
maybe there was another personality
because you did mention Alice so there
might be another character there might
be another thing oh yeah that's right
dang that's funky that's cool though I'm
just walking around
oh good clue good clue good clue wish we
knew it Brannon better we know Brandon
Brandon ones room
I'll just override the lock frittata so
now we can no smoother no joke here we
go I'm waiting for Strauss can I borrow
to pack up their stuff head downstairs
I'll meet you there seems like they were
getting ready to leave
put some lady telling Brandon to murder
you got that from the intercom must be a
transmission buffer hang on that's Alice
coaster would you guess they even knew
of each other interesting okay all right
so this Alice person if I could load up
oh hey um sorry nevermind cute parents
or a Gamow origami nope I'm really I'm
really a mess thinking about the scan
everyone is being so brave all smiles no
regrets you know how he said you would
hold my hand during the scan if the
offer still stands I gratefully accept
if we do it together we could suffer the
hangover together as well they say it
takes a couple days to recover there's a
note from Alice that makes me think she
was scanned alongside Brandon okay that
sounds really promising
definitely use that okay I think we got
this Simon I can synthesize Alice's
voice from the intercom and use it to
impersonate her for the simulation if
you trick them into feeling safe enough
to open up sounds really shady
definitely feeling good about this good
job with the intercom I didn't know you
could date in mine what's it look it's
just something that I do now sir comes
naturally to you what's really
interesting is it added to my dating
profile
Robo dating Akers finally agreed to
evacuate Delta Khoya courier and I moved
into theta Akers said he'd stick around
a while longer that crazy bastard take
pride in my work but goddamn the place
of miserable since the driver stopped
sending parts did my orcs get together
without suggesting they were together
during the scan focus on simulating Brad
anymore come on man try on ear strum I
went ballistic and shut down all future
scans apparently Conrad wanted in on the
continuity just fried himself right in
the pilot seat something tells me we'll
beginning new security sensors quorum
Bay okay all right there we go then
okay so I have everything that I need
that was exit simpler than I thought it
took me a little bit of wandering around
but I eventually figured it out cuz I'm
a big sports Marty smoo now I'm gonna
shove my chip back into the slot and
then simulate some other ladies voice is
much more that we can use so she'll be
with Brandon simulation sorter I'll
still need to do the talking but it'll
sound and look like Alice okay
should I also question why you're able
to do this
whoa see that wasn't so bad
from I really got me worked up bastard
well that's what you get for this [ __ ]
stories
cuz I have it coming about struggler
he's sending you to the east side for
ASAP what should I tell him torrent I
could talk to him
wait didn't I just tell you to take easy
don't worry I'm not gonna tell me I
could feel all over okay
it's 1729 over 40 to 12 over 407 yeah
I'm sorry too long right
goodbye
wait oh that's sad da we need that what
we are simulations yeah but it shouldn't
make any difference you're still you I'm
not sure what to do with the data you
decide oh man
da you gotta leave this choice up to me
what what do you mean you don't know
what to do with the data you're just off
putting an ethical choice onto my
shoulders oh man uh see you see the
thing is that it's just data right it's
just dead in its in its actuality right
now it's just data it only becomes
something substantial once you start it
up and that's that's the time when
Brandon comes back to life but he's like
data starts to run the simulation of his
life starts to go so what do i do do I
want to open all up to the potential of
that ever happening again or do I want
to race data considering the idea that
one day he could be brought back in a
suit just like me who really knows these
things why would anyone know okay here's
my interesting conundrum because some of
you people might think that I would
automatically want to erase the data
considering what I the choice I made for
the person outside but the only reason I
pulled the plug on the person outside is
because she was literally trapped in
that machine and wasn't gonna be able to
ever go anywhere and was just kind of
stuck there wandering alone if you
started that program back up or got
power to that machine outside she would
still come back like I'm not I'm not up
to the task of just deleting everyone
who's been copied but I may have to make
that choice down the road but for now I
kind of just want to put it back into
storage like that's really I can't even
put it back into storage you won't let
me put it back into storage it would
just be stuck there it would just be
stuck here oh I can't even do it anymore
well I guess I made my choice but god
damn it yeah I was this is what I was
gonna do anyway I wasn't exactly going
to do anything with the with the data
I was just kind of gonna I don't know
shut down or something
yeah I don't think it's it's against my
better judgement to say that I would
delete his data because the data by
itself is just data it's it's not
anything else I mean yes could be
brought back and yes could be brought
back in a bad way but God we can get to
the done back get back here
okay will do she's facing all of my
inner demons at the moment okay
some Bad's gonna happen before I get
there isn't it we shall see is that the
sound of something bad happening is
someone still a crunch aah munching over
here so you're not worried that there
are other Simons or Catherine's running
around out there now I am jeez Simon
some thoughts are better left alone huh
yeah that's the that's the other thing
weird weird
just warming up the done back for us
spine collecting that's for one so it
might need a minute okay that's it
that's everything let's go ahead and ha
that's weird
never mind what do you need me to do
head inside the dock the Omni tool can
open the door now and get into the done
back then plug me in and I'll take a sit
to the abyss
what do you saying you know you said
something was weird said some do daddy
was weird something going on
you want to tell me about maybe I guess
I could have opened the door long ago I
didn't have to necessarily be going in
and out of the window slicing up all my
Robo parts on the cut glass okay I'm
still just gonna ignore all the blood
ooba-dooba to move it over to room why
do I have such a bad feeling about all
this I've gotten credibly bad feeling do
I need to move that ladder as ellas here
oh I do I do need to move the ladder
ah how did I know I'm such a smart man
my genius intellectual is just sometimes
a burden for me to be this smart okay I
was just reading the subreddit that I
found this new one called our I am very
smart is making fun of people that are
way too up their own ass about how smart
they are or how smart they think they
are well apparently I'm not smart at all
cuz I can't even move the ladder over
this gap well [ __ ] I hate [ __ ] I never
mind I can't even get it through I
should be on are I am smart oh man okay
anyway so now what what well I can dig
this
I can't go up the oh it was already in
the place it needed to go okay so about
me being smart mm-hmm
never mind that doesn't work either I am
failing spectacular oh there's a
computer uh okay here
jiggle jiggle Oh wiggle wiggle wiggle
wiggle
I need these do them hmm oh how about
the power plug here
Oh blink I got it
[ __ ] bonk really what are we ready for
example hey thank you walkie yeah
okay what the hell happened why does
that happen
there was obviously a personality in the
dun bat now I've got a vengeful dun bat
and now there's a vengeful angry done
bat swimming around the water how is
that good Catherine where can i plug you
in I needed verse I need lots of advice
oh this looks bad oh no oh no this goes
right into the laboratory what oh thank
you for the loading but why would I want
to now which way am I facing I don't
know which way I'm facing anymore well
why would I want to go into the
laboratory there was a lot of crunch and
Munch and plan B achievement unlocked
GRA good all right so that's actually
all the time that I have for this
episode in the next one I'm actually
gonna be going into the laboratory and
seeing what everything's going on down
there and it already sounds like this
party started so I need to get down
there so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
Hugo